>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE PROMISE OF AN AMERICA CREDIT
SOCIETY IS AT THE MOST CAPABLE
PEOPLE WILL RISE TO THE OCCASION
OF THE GREATEST AUTHORITY.
IN A MERITOCRACY YOU'D HIGHER
HEART SURGEONS BECAUSE A GOOD
HEART SURGERY NOT BECAUSE OF HOW
THEY LOOK AT HER WITH HER
PARENTS ARE.
A MERITOCRACY'S CEILING WHERE TO
RUN SOCIETY.
PLUS IT WORKS WELL.
FEWER PEOPLE DIED ON THE
OPERATING TABLE WHEN YOU DO IT
THAT WAY.
FOR GENERATIONS THIS IS HOW
AMERICAN SOCIETY RAN.
IF YOU WERE SMART AND WORK
TARGET COULD COMPETE AGAINST
ANYONE ELSE IN AMERICA.
IT WAS TRUE.
IT WAS CALLED THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
PEOPLE MOVED HERE FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD TO PARTAKE IN THAT
SYSTEM.
BUT THERE WAS A PEARL ABOUT
DIRECT POLITICAL PROBLEM WITH
IT.
IF YOU HAVE A MERITOCRATIC
SOCIETY IT'S HARD TO PLAY
BASEBALL TEXT BECAUSE RACE PLAYS
NO PART IN ADVANCEMENT.
GROUP INTERESTS ARE IRRELEVANT
IN A MERITOCRACY.
IT MAY SOUND IDYLLIC TO YOU, THE
KIND OF COUNTRY LEVEL EVENT.
BUT FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IT
WAS DISASTER.
HOW DO YOU GET YOUR ODORS TO THE
PULSE OF THEY'RE NOT RACIALLY
GRIEVED?
IT'S HARD.
SO THAT THE TAIL END OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT, DEMOCRATS
INTRODUCED A NEW CONCEPT: THEY
CALLED IT AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION.
THE IDEA WAS TO PUNISH OR REWARD
AMERICANS BASED ON THE COLOR OF
HIS CABIN.
IRONICALLY THIS WAS PRECISELY
THE EVIL PRACTICE OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT WAS DESIGNED TO
ABOLISH.
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION WAS
UNEQUIVOCALLY WRONG, THAT WAS
THE WHOLE POINT OF THE MARCH ON
WASHINGTON.
OPEN NO, SAID DEMOCRATS.
ACTUALLY, RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
CAN BE GOOD AT IT ALL DEPENDS ON
WHO WAS BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST, THERE WAS ARGUMENT.
THAT STILL THEIR ARGUMENT MORE
THAN 50 YEARS LATER.
BUT EVEN NOW, AFTER ALL THIS
TIME, MOST PEOPLE WHO CAN
EXPLAIN IT CLEARLY DON'T REALLY
BUY IT.
WAIT, I CAN HAVE A JOB OR GET A
JOB BECAUSE I WAS BORN WITH THE
WRONG SKIN COLOR?
THAT SOUNDS WRONG.
AND OF COURSE THE RIGHT.
AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION IS WRONG.
IT'S TOTALLY IMMORAL.
IT'S COMPLETELY UNFAIR.
ENOUGH OF THE FIRST TIME IN
YEARS, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
BEING FORCED TO DEFENDANT IN
PUBLIC.
THE SUPREME COURT IN JUST NOW
CONSIDERING A CASE ABOUT
AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION IN COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS AT HARVARD.
DEMOCRATS ARE DEFENDING THE
INDEFENSIBLE WITH MAXIMUM
FEROCITY.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR HIM THAT'S HOW
THAT IS WHO YOU DO.
AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION IS NORMALLY
THE DEFINITION OF RACISM IT'S
ALSO HIGHLY EMBARRASSING IN ITS
PARTICULARS.
THE CLOSER YOU GET TO IT THE
MORE EMBARRASSING IT IS.
WHEN YOU ELEVATE PEOPLE ON THE
BASIS OF THEIR APPEARANCE, YOU
TEND TO GET NOT IMPRESSIVE
PEOPLE.
WHY WOULD YOU?
UNLESS YOU'RE BUYING SUNSCREEN,
SKIN TONE IS A TOTALLY RELEVANT
CRITERIA.
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR
OPENLY CONCEDES THAT SHE GOT HER
JOB BECAUSE OF AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION, SHE WAS COMPLETELY AND
DEMONSTRABLY UNQUALIFIED FOR THE
POSITION.
OBAMA CHOSE HER BECAUSE OF THE
WAY SHE LOOKED.
THAT MAY SOUND DERANGED BUT IT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED, NOBODY SET
DISPUTES AT.
TODAY WAS OF THE CONSEQUENCES.
SO TO MY ARM MADE A MISTAKE THAT
KNOW YOUR FIRST YEAR LAW SCHOOL
STUDENT WHATEVER MAKE.
SHE CONFUSED THE TERMS TO
FECTEAU AND TO ENSURE.
THAT'S AN INCONCEIVABLE MISTAKE.
IT'S LIKE CONFUSING GASOLINE
WITH DIESEL FUEL.
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN BECAUSE THE
TERMS OF AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
MEANINGS.
DEFECTIVE MEAN SOMETHING NONE OF
THE LAW BUT HAPPENS ANYWAY.
DOES SURETY MEAN SOMETHING
HAPPENING THAT SANCTIONED BY THE
LAW.
SEE THE DISTINCTION?
OF COURSE YOU DO.
AND YOU'RE NOT EVEN A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
BUT SO MY ARM DOESN'T SEE IT.
WATCH.
>> SO EVEN IF WE HAD TO SURE OF
DISCRIMINATION NOW, SEGREGATION
NOW, CONGRESS CAN'T LOOK AT
THAT.
WE CERTAINLY HAVE SURE
SEGREGATION.
RACISTS ARE TREATED DIFFERENTLY
AND A SOCIETY IN TERMS OF THEIR
ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY.
>> THAT'S WHAT JUSTICE JUST
SAID.
WAS THIS WOMAN WEARING A ROBE?
EVEN AFTER JUSTICE ALITO
CORRECTED HER, SHE KEPT SAYING
THERE IS TO ENSURE SEGREGATION
IN 2022.
JIM CROSSED ON THE BOOKS.
OKAY.
THIS IS THE SOCIETY THAT
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION HAS CREATED.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE A MORE CASE
AGAINST AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION THAN
ITS RESULTS.
AND SO IS GOING TO BE THAT WAY
BECAUSE THE COLOR OF YOUR SKIN
IS IRRELEVANT.
AND IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT,
EVERYTHING FALLS APART.
SO AS THE ARGUMENT'S HIM ON, THE
CASE AGAINST AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION
SOMETHING STRONGER.
WATCH THIS EXCHANGE BETWEEN
BRETT KEVIN ON THE STATE'S
SOLICITOR GENERAL.
>> HER APPLICANTS FROM LITTLE
EASTERN COUNTRIES CLASSIFIED?
JORDAN, IRAQ, EGYPT, IRAN?
>> MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT JUST
LIKE OTHER SITUATIONS WHERE THEY
MIGHT NOT FIT WITHIN THE
PARTICULAR BOXES ON THE COMMON
APPLICATION, WE RELY ON SELF
REPORTING AND WOULD ASK, THEY
CAN VOLUNTEER THEIR PARTICULAR
COUNTRY FOR US.
>> BUT IF THEY HONESTLY CHECK
ONE OF THE BOXES, WHICH ONE?
>> I DO NOT KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION.
>> Tucker: .
JUST REMIND YOU SOMETHING YOU
PROBABLY NEVER THINK ABOUT, THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT COLLECTS DATA ON
PEOPLE'S RACES.
NOW IN A SOCIETY WHERE ARE ALL
EQUAL AS CITIZENS OF THE LAW,
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
THAT'S WHAT THE DID.
WHERE AGAINST KEEPING TRACK
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF RACE, ART
WAIT?
HOW DO WE DETERMINE SOMEONE'S
RACE WHEN THERE'S SO MUCH AT
STAKE, DO WE MEASURE THE SHAPE
OF PEOPLE'S HEADS AND TAKE BLOOD
TESTS?
IT'S REALLY DARK.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
THE QUESTION THAT EXCHANGE IS,
WHAT BOX TO THE MIDDLE EASTERN'S
CHECK CHRIS MARK NO IDEA!
SHOULD THEY IDENTIFY AS BLACK?
SELECTED SCHOOLS CURRENTLY BOOST
BLACK COMPLIMENTS TO THE POINT
ROOM LIGHTS ARE PENALIZED
THROUGH AN IMPORTANT TEN POINTS
ON THE CITY FOR BEING WHITE.
ASIANS ARE PENALIZED 450 POINTS
FOR BEING ASIAN.
TALK ABOUT SYSTEMIC RACISM.
HOW IS THAT ALLOWED?
GOOD QUESTION.
AND IF ANYTHING, THE SYSTEMIC
RACISM AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
IT IS, SO SOME OF THE INTENSIVE
LEVEL, HAS ACCELERATED IN THE
LAST DECADE.
AT HARVARD, SKIN COLOR WAS
DETERMINATIVE AND ADMISSIONS FOR
MORE THAN HALF OF ALL ADMITTED
AFRICAN AMERICAN APPLICANTS AND
ROUGHLY ONE-THIRD OF HISPANIC
APPLICANTS.
HOW PATRONIZING TO THEM BY THE
WAY.
FROM 2002 THROUGH 2017, IT'S ALL
JUST UNBELIEVABLE THE DIFFERENCE
THE STANDARDS ARE.
IT DOESN'T JUST HAPPEN AT
HARVARD OR OTHER SCHOOLS BUT THE
ENTIRE SOCIETY.
A FEW YEARS AGO SENIOR FELLOW
CALLED MARK PERRY FOUND BLACK
AND HISPANIC STUDENTS WERE
FAVORED HEAVILY FOR MEDICAL
SCHOOL.
THIS IS COMPARED TO WHITE
STUDENTS.
THEY WERE NINE TIMES MORE LIKELY
COMPARED ASIAN STUDENTS WITH
SIMILAR SCORES.
THAT'S MEDICAL SCHOOL.
IN THE END, YOU HAVE BAD
DOCTORS.
NOT BECAUSE AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS MADE BAD DOCTORS BUT
BECAUSE THE PROCESS OF PICKING
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF
IRRELEVANT CRITERIA LIKE THEIR
SKIN TONE IS INSANE.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
MEDICINE.
IN FACT, THE PRODUCT OF ITSELF
DISCREDITS THE MEDICAL SCHOOLS
THAT ENGAGE IN IT BECAUSE IT'S
SO ANTISCIENCE.
THIS SHOULD MAKE YOU UNEASY.
BUT WHEN IT GETS WORSE.
HERE'S AN EXCHANGE FROM TODAY.
CLARENCE THOMAS ASKED THE
SOLICITOR GENERAL WITH THE
BENEFITS OF AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION
MIGHT BE.
>> THE MOST CONCRETE POSSIBLE
SCENARIO STOCK TRADING.
THERE ARE STUDIES THAT FIND THAT
RACIALLY DIVERSE GROUPS OF
PEOPLE MAKE TRAININGS DECISIONS
PERFORM AT A HIGHER LEVEL.
THE MECHANISM THERE IS THAT IT
REDUCES GROUPTHINK AND PEOPLE
HAVE LONGER AND MORE SUSTAINED
DISAGREEMENT AND THAT LEADS TO
MORE EFFICIENT OUTCOME.
>> I CAN SIT ON PORCH LET'S
PORCH LET'S TALK IN TALK IN THAT
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD SIMILAR
ARGUMENTS IN FAVOR SEGREGATION
TWO.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
SO RACIAL QUOTAS TO INCREASE
GROUPTHINK?
AND ALLOW FOR A DIVERSITY
VIEWPOINT CHRIS MACK REALLY?
IN A SOCIETY THAT'S BY RACIAL
QUOTAS IS THERE A GREATER
SMALLER DIVERSITY THAT IS TO BE?
IT'S INSANE.
TO CLARENCE THOMAS IT'S ON
FAMILIAR, HE SAID HE'S HEARD
SIMILAR ARGUMENTS IN FAVOR OF
SEGREGATION.
GIMME THIS BECAUSE OF HOW IT IS
BORN, THAT'S THE ARGUMENT.
IT WAS WRONG THEN AND THAT'S
WRONG NOW.
THE DIFFERENCES WE NO LONGER
ACKNOWLEDGE THE VICTIMS OF IT.
MILLIONS OF THEM EXIST BY
DEFINITION.
THERE PEOPLE LIKE CAITLIN
YOUNGER, WHITE GIRL FROM TEXAS,
NO FAMILY CONNECTIONS OR
ADVANTAGE IS ALL SHE HAD WAS
HARD WORK AND INTELLIGENCE.
SHE SCORED A NEAR-PERFECT 1550
ON THE S.A.T.
APPARENTLY SHE THOUGHT THE
SYSTEM WAS FAIR ENOUGH TO REWARD
HER.
BUT SHE WASN'T REWARDED WHEN WE
KNOW WHY.
SHE WAS TURNED ON FROM EVERY
SELECTIVE COLLEGE SHE APPLIED TO
BECAUSE OF THE KING SKIN COLOR.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
HOW DO LIBERALS FEEL ABOUT THAT?
DOES ANYONE REALLY WANT TO LIVE
IN A COUNTRY LIKE THAT?
WELL IF YOU DO, KRISTEN CLARKE
DOES.
SHE RUNS THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DIVISION AT DOJ.
SHE DIDN'T GET THE JOB BECAUSE
SHE CARES ABOUT CIVIL RIGHTS.
NO.
SHE WAS HIRED BECAUSE SHE
OPPOSES CIVIL RIGHTS AND SHE HAS
HER ENTIRE PUBLIC LIFE IN 2020.
HER POLITICAL APPOINTMENT SHOULD
BE KILLED, SHE DECLARED.
IN RESPONSE TO A VIDEO OF PEOPLE
CHANTING FARAH FAUCI, SHE SAID,
DID THESE PEOPLE SHOULD BE
PUBLICLY IDENTIFIED AND NAMED,
BARRED FROM TREATMENT AT ANY
PUBLIC HOSPITAL IF AND WHEN THEY
FALL WELL DENIED COMMON DRUGS
DAEMONIC COVERAGE.
>> OH JUST THEM.
YES INDEED.
THEY CAN ASCEND TO POWER BECAUSE
THEY BECOME MORE POWERFUL, THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO CLAIM THAT THEY
ARE VICTIMS.
BUT THEY'RE NOT VICTIMS.
SHE WENT TO PRIVATE SCHOOL,
KRISTEN CLARKE.
SHE IS A PRODUCT OF PRIVILEGE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT EVEN
AS THEY TELL YOU
AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT SOCIAL POLICY, YOU
CAN'T ISOLATE ANYONE
INDIVIDUALLY.
IT'S TOTALLY NOT ALLOWED TO PUT
OTHER PEOPLE AT KRISTEN CLARKE.
ARE THOSE PROTECTED GROUPS
DOING?
ARE THEY BENEFITING FROM
GENERATIONS OF
AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION CHRIS
McDONALD OR NOT.
THE KIDS OF DOCTORS ARE
BENEFITING FROM AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION.
S.A.T. RESULTS FOR BLACK
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE STILL
ABYSMAL.
NO ONE'S HELPING THEM.
HOW ARE THEY BEING HELPED?
DO NOT BEING OUT.
THE CHILDREN OF NONPROFIT
EXECUTIVES AND DOCTORS WERE
SAYING CURTIS AND BARACK OBAMA,
THEY'RE ALL BENEFITING.
BUT THE PEOPLE WHO NEED IT OR
NOT GETTING ANY BENEFIT,
INFECTIVE BEING IGNORED.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS IN FAVOR
OF IT TODAY.
SCIENCE COMPELS A RACIAL'S
PAROLE SYSTEM.
THIS IS REAL.
>> THE SUPREME COURT COULD STEM
PROFESSIONALS, SCIENCE, MUST
STAND AGAINST THE WHITE
SUPREMACY AND SCIENTIFIC RACISM
THAT FUELS ARGUMENTS AGAINST IT.
>> SEE A WHITE IF YOU ARE
AGAINST RACIAL.
YOUR GOOD PERSON ARGUING AGAINST
BAD PEOPLE.
THEY CONVERTED THAT.
THEY'VE COWED PEOPLE INTO
SILENCE.
SO JOE BIDEN SOLICITOR GENERAL,
THE FORMER MISS IDAHO, HE HIRED,
ARGUE TODAY THAT
AFFIRMATIVE-ACTION IS SOMEHOW
VITAL FOR A NATIONAL SECURITY
TO.
>> OUR ARMED FORCES KNOWN FROM
HARD EXPERIENCE THAT WHEN WE DO
NOT HAVE A DIVERSE OFFICER CORPS
THAT'S REFLECTIVE OF
DIVERSIFYING FOR US, OUR
STRENGTH AND COHESION AND
MILITARY READINESS SUFFERED.
SO IT'S A CRITICAL NATIONAL
SECURITY AND PARENTING OBTAIN
DIVERSITY WITHIN THE OFFICER
CORPS.
AT PRESENT IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT DIVERSITY WITHOUT
RACE CONSCIOUS ADMISSIONS
INCLUDING OF THE NATION'S
SERVICE ACADEMIES.
THE MILITARY EXPERIENCE
RECOGNIZES WHAT THIS COURT
RECOGNIZED IN KRUGER WHERE IN A
SOCIETY WHERE RACE MATTERS IN
COUNTLESS WAYS UNFORTUNATELY,
ACHIEVING DIVERSITY CAN SOME
TIMES REQUIRE CONSCIOUS ACTS BY
RELIEVING EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS.
>> OKAY.
DOES SHE KNOW ANYTHING BUT THE
SUBJECT SHE DOESN'T.
U.S. MILITARY WAS THE SINGLE
MOST IMPRESSIVE INSTITUTION IN
AMERICAN LIFE FOR GENERATIONS
PRECISELY BECAUSE IT WAS
MERITOCRATIC.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ADVANCED ON THE
BASIS OF INDIVIDUAL EFFORT AND
NOT ON THE BASIS OF GROUP
INTEREST.
IT'S BEEN COMPLETELY CORRUPTED
AND THE MOST RECENT GENERATION
ON THAT CORRUPTION HAS
ACCELERATED UNDER JOE BIDEN AND
THE RESULT OF THAT IS THAT THE
ARMY IS NOW DRAMATICALLY SHORT
OF ITS RECRUITMENT GOAL BECAUSE
NO NORMAL PERSON OF ANY COLOR
WANTS TO JOIN OUR RATE SYSTEM.